[Music]
Safi welcome to the show thanks Tim glad
to be here and I'm gonna read your bio
here this is this is one of the one of
the several I would say interviews that
I've done where it's not going to be a
challenge as I said to one of my
employees earlier to find things to talk
about it's going to be a matter of
trying to ask you all the things I would
like to ask you but I'll give people
some context first so by way of bio Safi
book call you can find him on twitter at
Safi but call that's sa fi bah CA ll
received his PhD in physics from
Stanford and his undergrad degree from
Harvard after working as a consultant
for McKinsey safey Kovan and a
biotechnology company specializing in
developing new drugs for cancer he led
its IPO and served as its CEO for 13
years in 2008 Safi was named Ernst &
Young's New England biotechnology
entrepreneur of the year in 2011 he
worked with President Obama's Council of
science advisors on the future of
national research Safi you are most
recently author of loon shots that is
the title subtitle how to nurture the
crazy ideas that win wars cure diseases
and transform industries which has some
of the best cover blurbs I've ever seen
on any book we might talk about that
Daniel Kahneman does not give a lot of
blurbs for books loon shots describes
what an idea from physics tells us about
the behavior of groups and how teams
companies and nations can use that to
innovate faster and better it has been
selected for Washington Post's 10
leadership books to watch for 2019 inks
10 business books you need to read in
2019 and Business Insider's 14 books
everyone will be reading in 2019 that
would be good for you if that's if this
ends up being the case and we go back a
ways so I've been really excited to
catch up because our lives have changed
quite a lot oh yeah since we last we're
spending a lot of time together and I
thought we could just start at the very
beginning so could you describe for
people how we first met
and a little bit of the context all
right sure so we were at its this may be
10 years or so ago and we were at
a at the Sundance in where's Sundance
Sundance is in Utah it's Sundance in
Utah and there's a conference organized
every year by Peter teal and or in
Hoffman and Oren's a good friend of mine
for many years and I was sitting at a
lunch table and I just taken up as sort
of a hobby triathlon long distance
triathlon and I had just learned for the
first time reel swimming not just sort
of splashing around in a pool but how to
you know how can you can splash around a
pool you can swim it you know a couple
laps and you get tired but that's not
going to help if you want to swim 1.2
miles in the ocean so I had found this
course called Total Immersion and I was
just having such a blast like because it
takes you from you know a 2 out of 10 to
like a 5 to 7 take really really quickly
so you go you can like knock out 1.2
miles no problem so sitting at lunch and
somehow there was this guy kind of quiet
but happy guy at next to me and he had
also just taken up total immersion
swimming and then we just totally
connected on how amazing it was and like
how it can transform your swimming and
how it's a metaphor for life and I
started using that as a metaphor for
learning and it breaking down everything
you know about life about like a swim
stroke and all the bad habits that you
learn and replacing them and how
interesting it is such as small little
tweaks can take you so rapidly from a 2
out of 10 to a 6 out of 10 or a 7 or an
8 and what kind of a joy that is and how
that can apply in so many areas of life
and this other guy is sitting next me
was like yes exactly the same way and
then since then we've been friends and
total immersion in a way is such a
perfect introduction and metaphor for a
lot of what you do in life and what
impresses me about you and as you
mentioned a great example of learning
something in a
a typical way all right because it's not
just looking at the small things that
have a disproportionate output or
testing them but also it is
fundamentally about testing assumptions
right and for those people who don't
know we won't spend the entire interview
on total immersion but it's it's a great
lead-in because speaking of someone
who's born and raised on Long Island
surrounded by water had a few near
drowning experiences when I was very
young I did not learn how to swim
meaning I could not do to and fro in a
decent-sized pool until my 30s and had a
really acute fear of water and after
about a week of total immersion by
myself with a book keep in mind not even
video at that point was doing 20 30 laps
at a time and finding it relaxing which
is just bonkers to think about and I'd
failed up to that point even though
another friend Chris Sacca had actually
no it wasn't Chris Sacca at that point
before that another friend Chris
Ashenden had assigned me in New Year's
resolution we realized were more likely
to actually fulfill our nears
resolutions if we assign each other
resolutions with sort of rewards and
punishments and mine was to do a
one-kilometer open water swim and his
was drink nothing stronger than green
tea for a year because he liked double
espressos but I had failed up to that
point in part because every lesson
started the same way which was here's a
kickboard
and go do two hen laps in the pool and
after a lap and a half I'm like I can't
even feel my legs I'm so tired right and
the lesson was as good as done and then
you take total immersion and one of the
first things Terry Laughlin encourages
you to think about is minimizing the
legs and minimizing drag and it's just a
rethinking of the entire of the entire
approach to swimming so you more than
almost anyone I've met I feel like 10
years that we're like having the same
conversation again
years ago and you know the really cool
thing about it the way it applies to so
many areas of life that I found is it
starts by a counterintuitive take on
something that everybody does or
believes is true
and that is well if you're swimming
forward you want to see where you're
going so you raise your head and so
that's exactly what's wrong with
swimming with most like casual swimming
because then you're like kicking your
feet to maintain horizontal balance and
by kicking your feet you're using you
know 80 or 90 percent of your energy is
just going to correct bad position
that's why you're tired and so in so
many areas of life when you learn this
kind of bad habit that's this very
natural that every human does once you
become self-aware of that it's really
not hard to just put your head down yeah
and don't get that's it that's basically
the magic you put your head down and
don't kick and that's it and then so
many different areas of life it turns
out they're these bad habits these
things that you think you should be
doing your program to do or everybody
tells you to do
and they create drag and going through
life and then someday somebody maybe
it's Tim Ferriss says you know here's
this really counterintuitive weird trick
don't do that do this and all of a
sudden the drag goes away and you can
swim a mile and you know I actually
think it reminds me of mentioned we were
talking a little bit about Danny
Kahneman and how he transformed
economics it's very similar right
because what he said you know for
economists for 200 years had said oh
there's one way to think about you know
incentives and how they influence
behavior everybody calculates you know
net present expected value of my
financial return doing X and doing Y and
if X is greater than Y I do X the
recessional actors it's right and
condiment just said you know I'm a
psychologist and that's like [ __ ]
that's just not what happens that's not
what people do people operate on these
little rules of thumb and sometimes X
may rashly be greater than Y but they do
Y anyway for these reasons and it was
it's not rocket it was a very simple
adjustment like hold your head flattened
don't kick yeah it was basically saying
hey humans are humans they're not
calculators that's it yeah and that
transformed economics so there you see
just like this
total immersion swimming trick which
changes swimming is what condiment did
for economics had changed economics with
this one idea they actually humans are
humans they operate on some heuristics
not NPV calculations any comments right
that's not possible they operate on NTV
like I don't think so I kind of know
humans and they don't do that which in
retrospect sounds sort of obvious but it
was a big big change yeah it's you know
more well you've forgotten more probably
in the last week than I'll ever know
about physics but it as a layman who's
interested in science but by no means a
a real scientist it makes me think of
richard fineman and i'm gonna i'm going
to butcher this i'm sure but something
along the lines of it doesn't matter how
pretty your theory is if it doesn't fit
with experiment it's wrong that's right
and there's a lot of disregarding
perhaps the obvious in favor of this
these legacy theories that just do not
fit that sort of the the reality that is
it is right in front of you funny
well maybe not funny but little-known
fact I was actually subject in son of
some of Kahneman's studies when I was an
undergrad I did vermei four dollars an
hour or whatever hitting a space bar
it's like logical studies in Green Hall
that's right people he was at Princeton
and you were at Princeton and actually
that's sort of the connection like I
think he was a neighbor with my mom and
dad because I grew up in Princeton oh
right I didn't that's we'll talk about
we'll talk about growing up in towns
like Princeton in another time I didn't
grow up in Princeton I grew up in the
end of Long Island which has some
similar dynamics let's let's zoom out a
bit and we're gonna do this quite a bit
in this conversation I think because I
want to talk about Safi the individual
and your personal practices and your
thinking because I think there's a lot I
don't think there is a lot to explore
there you you are one of the most
systematic people I know but I also want
to give people the context on your
career and some of what you've done
and your past because I think it's
helpful and we were just talking about
Terry Laughlin who passed away not all
too long ago and he was hospitalized
short shortly after just before and then
shortly after my my interview with him
which was the last long for an interview
he ever did and he had cancer and then a
stroke it was a complication and a
number of things following the knee
passed away which was very sad what is
your history with cancer in the sense
that why did you get involved with
anything related to cancer well I was I
started in academic science and
theoretical physics and after a few
years and this may be a personality flaw
but I and it's taken me many years to
appreciate this but I really get excited
all right I'll explain this in physics
geek language and then I'll try to
create there's this saying the way I
think about it is I couple to the
derivative and I'll expect that down so
the derivative is a slope so you know
zero derivative means no slope and big
derivative means a very high slope and
in physics when you say you coupled to
something at you know an electron is
traveling along and has some coupling
constant to the photon and that's how it
interacts with light and that's always
the case and so when I say I coupled to
derivative means that I derive energy
from the slope from the slope of
learning and so when I started in
theoretical physics I was learning an
enormous amount and then after I I was
in one area of theoretical physics
called
particle physics it's a science of the
very small what happens inside a proton
or a neutron quarks and after a few
years I sort of felt like I had you know
gotten very deep in that tunnel and I
wasn't learning as much and it the I
mean there were you know not gonna
exaggerate there was a ton still out
there to learn but it wasn't like
drinking from a firehose like starting
off feeling like an imposter or starting
off
being barely able to swim one lap and
then going to swimming a kilometer no
problem and you know physics has got
particle physics has gotten a little
stuck in the last twenty or thirty years
in some sense which we can talk about
some other time so I switched to a
totally different area after about five
years and then I got into the business
world I realize I'm kind of far from
your cancer question that's okay but
it's I switched out of academic science
because after about five years you know
in each of these areas I felt like I'd
sort of learned and I wanted to learn
something new so I went into the
business world went into McKinsey didn't
know anything about I didn't even own a
suit actually I remember taking for a
weird little story I loved digressions
for weird story yes I'll remember well
if need be and I don't think that I'm
getting kind of far from your game
that's a question that's now but like
sort of a funny story so it's kind of
how I got ended up in cancer and I
started off in this weird physics play
so I I'd only I basically hadn't set
foot off for university until I was
thirty because I you know my parents are
academic scientists we just went to
Princeton and so I spent a lot of time
around there and then college grad
school postdoc and then I was sort of
getting a little like is this what I
want to do for the rest of my life just
you know write papers and grants and
referee and the same conferences so I
started exploring as some friend had
been to this company called McKinsey
which I'd never heard of and they said
like interesting problem-solving it's
sort of like alright I'll do that sign
you know sent an application interview
comes and my friend told me you need to
wear a suit and I'm like wow I I haven't
had a suit since my bar mitzvah 18 years
ago whatever so I asked like where do
you buy a suit me and so I got the name
of a place and I went and it was just
like incredible place for these super
expensive clothes and like it was the
most amazing thing I'd ever seen it was
called the Men's Wearhouse
and so I bought a suit and I felt like a
million I paid like a hundred and twenty
dollars or something I was like this is
like 10x more than I've ever paid for
any clothing either and I and I and I
felt like a million bucks and I I fly to
New York for this interview with this
firm and I you know I remember coming
into the city and like getting off and
going walking up Park Avenue and I'm
wearing like this old beat-up ski jacket
because that you know I just would go
skiing and I didn't realize that people
also have some fancy jacket so everybody
around me is wearing the cycle okay you
know blue now I know like the overcoat
exactly so I got this like I feel like a
million bucks because I have this 120
dollar Men's Wearhouse sued and like you
know I probably spent eighteen dollars
on the Men's Wearhouse tie and I'm
feeling really extravagant and then I'm
like walking down the street I have this
beat-up old ski jacket with like still
the ski tags hanging off of it on top of
your Men's Wearhouse and I'm like why am
I the only one wearing this on this
whole sphere I'm like AHA that's weird
and so then I get to my interview I like
I hide the jacket in my coat closet
before I get in there but anyway I did
that and that was drinking from a fire
hose because I'd like never set up foot
off for university and all of a sudden
I'm wearing a suit and I'm more in a
suit and well like since my bar mitzvah
and then they throw you I mean they'd
you can't they take time to sort of
educate you a little bit online and that
was super fun all these you know
professors fly in to just educate you
know I'm like this is the best thing
ever
they're paying me and all these
professors have been flying into like
this four-week course to this on this
resort with you know 30 people from all
over the world we're really interesting
people my age and people are flying and
just to teach us like all day long and
like this is like this is awesome and
I'm learning all this new stuff and I
was drinking from a firehose and was
sort of going from you know it well in
this case was a zero out of town I'd
never even balanced a checkbook like if
I had six dollars to buy a burrito in
San Francisco I was happy like that's
awesome
and but after a couple years you're like
oh okay now I got like what people do
for a living and how it works and the
business stuff and then I was like how
do I combine you know I don't think I
just want to be a guy who sort of
whispers to people here's what you might
want to do if you want to build your
business I wanted to sort of do
something but I wanted to do something
back in the science world and also
something that was more about either you
know let's make more money which is you
know what big companies are trying to do
as a consultant you're trying to help
them and in academia it's about the
search for truth so I wanted to do
something different that would feel like
it may be a little corny or cliche but
you're helping people who are suffering
and there's something you could be very
selfish about it there's something just
very satisfying even if you just think
at the local level like there's a kid in
a hospital bed and family's gonna lose
that kid and if something you can do
could help save that kid and so that
family and they could have a decades of
life together even if that's just one
kid that feels so much more satisfying
than you know having X or Y or Z in the
bank or even publishing another original
research paper so that's on your right
if you can see a family experiencing
life together for decades and they might
not have that's incredibly satisfying
and so I sort of stumbled into cancer to
get back to your question because that
was a really hot researcher this was
1819 years ago that was a really
exciting area and there was really very
little progress made in that area and
I'd spent about six months or a year
kind of talking to scientists at
different universities who had might
have some promising ideas and didn't
want to work with venture capitalists
and thought that physics was sort of
like this exotic we are bird and so I
always sort of
they were just like who is this guy
who's coming to talk to us about biology
and chemistry and medicine on oncology
needs a physicist so it was a mutual
interest there and eventually started a
company and just got more and more into
it into it and interested in seeing
these individual lives and how little
progress had been made and how many good
ideas were floating around and if I
could make a difference bridging some of
those ideas into into the real world
into the commercial world into the
business world into the industry where
they could become drugs that could save
lives even if you just save one kid help
one family that would feel incredibly
satisfying more satisfying than writing
a paper making money so that's kind of
how I got into cancer and oncology and I
wanted thank you for that I had never
heard of the Men's Wearhouse story
either this is this is a thinks
something I wanted to establish early on
because it gives incase Univ where you
were pointed right and then when we get
into the the habits and the routines and
the frameworks and so on that you use
personally or within organizations it it
shows some of the how but I wanted to at
least get to some of the why first let's
let's take a bit of a 90-degree turn and
this is gonna seem strange but I thought
this would be a good illustration of not
not just Safi the sort of scientific
innovator but you you the person because
they go together and so I'm gonna kind
of read what I think is that what I
think is a quote this is in in doing
research for having this conversation
which is always a little strange when
I'm doing research on my close friends
and it feels like I'm doing something
illicit in any case I want you to I'm
gonna read something and then you can
give us context for what this what this
is and why why you have this habit or
had it I would get so excited when I
stumbled across
perfect passage and it's beautiful music
out preserve it in an Evernote file
without my phone at dinner and read that
passage to whoever my poor dinner
companion happened to be pounding the
table to the rhythm pointing out the
beauty and the choices see how he did X
here and not Y that's why it works
silence no one cared but I enjoyed it
what is this about a hung man oh yeah
you find this stuff but I had to do with
another deed so I was with this company
that I started for 13 or so years and
then through a weird series of
coincidences and stumbles and different
things ended up writing in writing and
so first I wrote a kind of a long-form
essay and then you know it was 15,000
words i d't it a lot and people seem to
like it and then some much more
experienced author friends and
journalist friends were like nobody
publishes 15,000 word essays anymore
that's a book also you have a lot of
ideas in here and that needs to be
fleshed out it's too much so that turned
into a book and as I started with
writing I kind of broke it down a little
like swimming like what are the you
think you know people tell you a bunch
of stuff and the more you get into it
the more you realize a lot of stuff that
people tell you is really not very
helpful or often wrong and could you
give any examples oh just like don't use
passive voice there are actually some
great reasons you do want to use passive
voice but if you I get this picture of
like this old-school mama like hitting
you with a ruler from the $90.00 you as
passive voice never use passive voice I
always use active voice and then you
read some of these like phenomenally
beautiful passages and you look in them
and they're using passive voice left and
right and like really because these guys
pretty like some of these guys have won
the you know Nobel Prize for example a
relative president they're using so why
and just for people who are could you
give an example of active and passive
voice for people who may not be familiar
with
the you know active voice is Johnny flew
the helicopter to go put out it to go
you know videotape the fire and then
Lisa Friday I don't like do these things
a helicopter was brought in to go mm-hmm
you know view the fire from high above
and filming for video and so in the
helicopter was brought in is kind of
passive Johnny flew the helicopter now
in this case for example why would you
want to use the passive voice well if
you're telling a story you're telling
the story of the fire do you really need
to know that Johnny flew that helicopter
to put out that fire I think this is an
example on something I seem like that
specific helicopter
do you really it's actually kind of
distracting because johnny is kind of
irrelevant to this story so what you're
doing is you're inserting something in
the readers mind that's an irrelevant
distraction that you'll never come back
to and that just is a glitch in the
storyteller so that's one example of why
you want to use but there are many
examples of why you want to use but
anyways as part of I found that I people
that sort of said oh you're a pretty
good writer I think that's meaning for
like a physicist so that's a really low
bar and or even a you know a CEO or a
public company like that's a really low
bar you're pretty good for a public
company executive I'm like thanks that's
like I'm the one point five out of a
better than one but I just started to
find it fun to try to break down writing
like you break down swimming or break
down other things and then how do you
train to get better and so I read a lot
and eventually I came up with a kind of
a training and I would write you know I
dropped my daughter off at school in the
morning and come back kind of locked
myself from this little 8x8 cave shut
down everything and just do one of the
three sort of modes of writing whether
you're reading your writing or
editing and you know five six o'clock
pick my daughter up from school and
daycare bring her back dinner and then
my wife would check out at like 7:30 H
gets up really early and she was just
done so from 8 o'clock on every day for
almost two years I would bring out one
of actually just a couple books and
often I would just go we were living on
Mass Ave and Cambridge and so there are
a lot of great bars a little restaurant
I never go to the bar counter get a you
know a burger pizza or something in a
beer and I would spend the next two
hours usually just on two paragraphs it
released the same books or different
books each time they're consistently
this almost always the same actually I
would focus on probably two books and I
would just dissect a paragraph or two
from those two book for almost a year
and and that was one of the other things
like with swimming you know everybody
says keep your head up or its natural to
keep your head up there's this natural
inclination to try to read a ton read
widely read all these authors and you
get all these lists of here's my
favorite 20 authors like oh I should
read those 20 there's somebody else's
favorite 20 oh I should read those 20
and so I kind of threw all that out and
said I'm gonna actually focus on I don't
know much about literature I never you
know I did sports and I did like math
and science and that's it I really
didn't read it so I didn't so I have
like a big gap in but I picked two books
that really resonated for me what did
you pick in the bulk of short stories
and I'll explain why and Donald hall
essays after 80 and this is for just to
develop an ear for writing and I just
read a paragraph or two or three from
those books each night and then I would
break it down like why did this guy use
I wasn't reading for content
was just reading for years so Nabokov I
had read a little bit of this and a
little bit of that and reading here and
then I picked some friend I think and
sent me pointed me in an embellished
short source and brother I should say I
don't think I've read anything else if
is that just that one and when I opened
it up two at random the book of short
stories and I started reading his
sentences like my jaw dropped I didn't
know the English language could do that
how is this guy doing that it's probably
sort of like your sports thing like a
Hanna even with athletes like how how
the freaking hell is this guy doing it
and it's just so different at such a
higher level than anyway so that's why I
would take two paragraphs at a time or
three paragraphs and I'd say why did he
put this word here in this sentence and
not there because the natural thing
would be let's say to make it active
voice or the natural thing would be do
why did he use this transition from this
sentence the end of this once at the
beginning or the end of this paragraph
suppose I do it differently
it just sounds worse why why does it
sound worse when I move this word and he
could have picked any word they're like
six words you could imagine that mean
this thing why did he pick this one let
me try a different one and then oh it
just sounds worse and I would just do
that repeatedly and now but Nabokov I
picked because his sentences and and
rhythm and musicality of his writing
which is like jaw-dropping and everyone
like everyone is a ten out of ten it's
not like others are great sentence or a
great pass not a one-hit wonder it's
yeah it's just like how the freaking
hell does this guy do this and again I
have to say I'm not in literature guy or
an English guy and there's 99% of like
famous authors I've not read I just
couldn't believe listen so I was how
does this guy do this but it was and one
side after doing this sort of over and
over and then really that there were a
few other beautiful passages I've done I
would capture them in my Evernote and
then I would highlight the word like why
this word in yellow and then sometimes I
would bold like he did a lot of who uses
a lot of alliterations and I would
highlight the first letters just as
she's alliterations and then I would
highlight the transition
and then I would break down the
transitions between paragraphs into like
well there's seven different types of
transitions here's an example of one
you're singing oh this is the pivot
transition and and so I started to get a
sense of of that and I started having
this weird experience after doing this
for a year or so which was I would read
passages and I would hear music and I
would hear them I would hear them in my
head but but as music and a song so when
I was read for example in the book if I
would hear this is a little weird to say
all this stuff because it's like private
internal Minds I think I've talked about
it out loud is the podcast with that
yeah nobody listens to the right gnosis
to me I just handful of our best friends
it's just you and me right since all
private stuff
I always just hear this thing like music
and it was in perfect harmony and then I
pick up the newspaper I pick up some
other stuff for some random book and I
couldn't read more than two sentences
because it just sounded like clashing
well the transition and the and the use
of passive and it didn't need this work
could have been that where I'm like I
can't even read more than three
sentences because it's just it's grating
and then I go back to you know this
other thing where there was perfect
harmony and it was just musical it was
just I wouldn't even at some point I
just I wouldn't even know why but one
thing would just great might get like
these it's like somebody rubbing fingers
on chalkboard or like the air and the
other one is just like huh so could we
talk about decisions a bit more sure
okay because you are examining in that
case decisions of a writer so you're
you're doing us forensic analysis of why
certain things happen why certain
choices were made and this this may be a
natural place maybe not you can you can
tell me she talked a little bit about a
totally different field although
similar-sounding last name garry
kasparov okay yes yeah yeah could you
describe to me why you find Kasparov
interesting I anyway is for people who
don't know
okay another book that I really enjoyed
was his book life imitates chest I love
that book and a little bit for a lot of
reasons I have a real admiration of like
excellent chess players because it's
it's something that takes incredible
focus incredible commitment and people
who do it really well do something I
could never do and it's just it's so
impressive
so I've always found it fascinating to
follow learn about great chess players
and I actually I listen to some podcasts
you did with a guy named Josh Waitzkin
Waitzkin which was fascinating I
actually loved his book too and then
because of that I went guy I didn't know
who he was before got his book which was
awesome about you know the art of
learning love of learning the art of
learning the art of learning right yeah
you guys would love each other at some
point you should be yeah and I it cuz he
did chess and then did martial arts and
I did martial arts for a long time and
then physics so Kasparov as you mean it
was the longest reigning Chess Champion
in history and he wrote this book about
how life imitates chess where he kind of
breaks down what he did and it was it's
so fascinating but one particular lesson
really resonated for me as a mindset
shift for how to think about making
decisions or analyzing decisions both in
business life in in personal life so
Kasparov said kind of one of if not the
key to his success in chess was after a
game whether he won or lost rather than
say analyze the game by saying oh I
moved pawn to Bishop you know pawn takes
Bishop here and that was a bad move and
that lost the game so next time I
shouldn't do pawn takes Bishop rather
than analyze the move and the outcome
which is what most just play
- and you can call that kind of an
outcome mindset he analyzed how did I
arrive at the decision to make that move
not just so much the move itself but
what was I think what was my
decision-making process which series of
moves did I go through how long did I go
through them what did I consider in what
order
how did I prepare for the match and how
did that affect my all these sort of met
a level not the outcome itself but one
step above which is what was my process
that I used to arrive at that decision
and given that it was a bad decision
where did that process break down in my
decision and therefore how should I
tweak my decision-making process for
that and he said that one ingredient
keep asking why keep asking why did you
make that decision you call that sort of
a system mindset let's analyze the
system rather than the outcome that's
one higher level and then has enormous
power and leverage because once you
tweak your process if you can identify a
weakness in your process and adjust that
process now not only next time won't you
do pawn takes Bishop which is about you
might do pawn does something else but
you've now improved your process which
can help you in 500 other situation
helping in one situation that can help
you 500 and so I took that and I call
that sort of system versus outcome
mindset and that can help you enormously
in personal life or in business life and
so that's the kasparov story and this
has extremely as you're saying
wide-ranging implications and
applications and this outcome versus
process distinction is also something
that comes up if you talk to any really
really high level poker player right
because you can have a great outcome
that is just dumb luck right you made it
you had a terrible decision-making
process or you threw caution to the wind
and really just you know flipped a coin
and hoped that you would get heads and
you did and so you're like oh wow
let me reward that decision-making
process which might have not been a
process
or you can you can make the the right
decision you can have a good process and
the deck is just stacked against you it
doesn't mean that you should stop making
decisions that way exactly right so you
really have to zoom out and you know
this is makes me also think of many many
other things right it's and on some
level all of life is investing right
you've finite time finite energy and
finite capital and even if the markets
can remain irrational longer than you
can remain solvent which is part of the
reason why really good poker players who
are thinking systematically also
understand the importance of having a
bankroll right right because if they
have a string of bad luck even with a
really really good strategy and
decision-making they need to be hold the
weather series of bad hands for instance
this is this is just such a critical
distinction and I don't want to be labor
it but I think it's something that that
I'd love to hear a little more about if
you could personalize it so how do you
how do you implement this yourself or
how have you in terms of doing post game
analysis on decisions right I think you
know at the business level it's exact
because people don't realize how much is
luck in real life whether it's an
invention or an innovation or launching
a new product so in the business level
and I'll tell you kind of a totally
different angle personal level but at
the business level you know there are
some pretty good teams or companies that
will try to do a post-mortem after some
product launches and they'll analyze but
they're still at that level one of
outcome mindset of we did pawn takes
Bishop and it didn't work so that's not
DuPont so I said we launched the product
and it didn't have this feature and
customers liked this feature and that's
why I didn't go as well so let's make
sure we have this feature so you're
still on kind of level one
the really really great teams and
there's in companies and not that many
of them say how did we arrive at that
decision to launch that product at that
time how do we make that decision who is
involved in the decision what
information did they have is that the
right people to help be making it are we
making the decisions in the right way
are we presenting the people who are
making the decisions with the right of
information at the right time analyzing
the right way and you see the difference
in one case you just learned let's not
put feature X on product Y in the other
case you learn something that can apply
to 500 different products let's think
about how we tweak our decision making
process in the future so that's sort of
system vs. outcome mindset on there you
know I started on the business side if I
could pause from yeah so on the business
side and this might apply elsewhere
other other questions you could ask when
trying to decipher what your
decision-making process was it why did
we think it was a good idea what were we
missing right what what information
didn't we have until to later I don't
know what the the right selection of
questions would be oh yeah sorry there's
so many like what are people's
individual incentives the people who are
involved in the decision so few people
ask that question are they really
incentivized by the project launch or
they have some other thing like I they
really focused on promotion so how does
being focused on promotion how did that
affect the decision and if we altered
their incentives might they have arrived
at a different decision so people rarely
ask let's just think about the X number
of people who are involved in the
decision let's walk through one by one
what are their incentive let's just
think about let's just have even a
20-minute conversation do we really
think the incentives are the right
incentives that are giving us the
decision that are aligning people with
the outcome or not
how are people communicating how are
people exchanging a you know are they
meeting the day of who's set of analyses
are they looking at somebody who really
knows what they're doing or not and did
they get present
the right data at the right time to make
the most informed now the real key is as
you sort of said with luck and cards you
want to do this for not just for
failures that's the wrong you want to do
it as much if not more for successes you
might have just gotten lucky those are
the most dangerous traps let's say you
like you kick you know in sport you kick
a soccer ball into the goal and you made
it you were five feet in front of the
goal keeping you keep right at the goal
keeper it just happens that the goal
keeper slipped on the mud or whatever it
was raining but you kick right at the
goal paper and you got it does that mean
you should keep kicking right at the
goal keeper that's the right strategy no
you just got lucky yeah you won the game
and maybe the world championship but you
got lucky do you want to do that again
next time no you bet on some dumb
internet stock and it quadrupled or
something and you had no idea what you
were doing and you were drunk when you
made the investment but you made
quadruple your wanting so does that tell
you want to be drunk before every
investment and not look at any due
diligence know you've got lucky so it's
more important to actually look at the
successes and think about how did I make
that decision than it is the failure
because everybody thinks hard about a
failure people rarely think about did I
get lucky they like to say oh I was my
genius bla bla bla they got so it's more
important as a team to say alright this
worked where did we get lucky where we
do we actually had flaws in our process
that we need to adjust next time in how
we made that we we were uninformed and
we simply got lucky our competitor
stumbled we just got lucky so we really
shouldn't the reason that's more
important is because it cements bad
habits so this is what we did last time
you know we got drunk before we made an
investment it was a great investment
let's get drunk again and make another
in fact it cements bad habits because
you confuse good outcome with good
decision making breath so that's on the
little business side so it can have a
pretty evict big effect on the personal
side as well like
you know one example as I give one
example for married people one example
for single people so a single one I
actually did you just feel personal but
whatever again it's just you and me
right just us okay good I kinda you know
you got to get into an argument with
your significant other and you find
yourself getting into an are you say
something about it or whatever the
dishes or you say something about the
driving or you see some and you know it
leads into an argument and the outcome
mindset is like well I said something
about the dishes don't tell you
something about the dishes in the future
so guess what's gonna happen you're
gonna have the same kind of argument
about 57 other subject because you're
not getting at the root what were you
thinking when you said that thing about
the dishes why were you thinking it what
state of mind were you in maybe you're
frustrated about something at work as an
example and you're mentioning some
nagging comment right what's the problem
really about the problem right and then
you say now I have a flaw in my system
where I'm frustrated at work and then it
comes out as a comment about something
that just is a bad idea it's a bad out
so maybe rather than just say don't ask
about the dishes next time and it comes
to say if I'm frustrated at work what
else can I do other than make comments
about the dishes like can I set up a
punching bag you know and just start
hitting the punching bag and take a
shower and then I'm in a better mood and
I don't give a [ __ ] about dishes or
whatever so you find what were you
thinking at the time when you made that
comment is there a tweak to your
decision-making process so that you
don't make not just that comment now
pawn takes Bishop but many other similar
things so that's married life for
example personal example single life
excellent when you and I knew each other
both were single I take you're still you
haven't I actually have a wonderful
girlfriend I've been with for a while
now and
things are going extremely well so we
can talk more about that we're at that
lid right so I was in living in
Manhattan as a single guy and the
company that I was running was in Boston
so I was just commuting back and forth
and I didn't have almost any social life
because it's so much time in the plane
and then we're dealing with running a
business so I would set up these
gathering some of which you came to us
in my apartment and I called them sway
scientists writers artists and
entrepreneurs and then eventually added
mostly because I was trying to exclude
them and eventually I just became
explicit no BLC no bankers lawyers are
consultants which which one should note
you used to be at McKinsey which is
great right no bankers lawyers or
consultant self-hating consultant yes I
call them Swain OBL see also because I
just don't remember stuff unless I have
it like an anti silly acronym resent you
know as I call this way no BLC and as
soon as I said especially when I added
the no BLC like interest sky rock
especially from the BLC crowd I like my
bank or lawyer or consulted friends will
like can I come on a waiter what part of
like nobody else I just said nobody else
in like yeah yeah but can I come can you
make him sit in like that's weird and
then single women in Manhattan like
really interesting intelligent
attractive women friends that we would
be like I am so there I am so want to
come and then I realized you know I was
sort of added but I realized like there
was such frustration among really
intelligent women professional women
they were so tired of like the same old
because New York is full of these you
know really ambitious bankers who are
just focused on banking and they were so
curious to meet scientists right so for
me I see scientists all day long and
writers I was sort of curious about and
I don't but anyway I ended up becoming
this really fun thing and I went out on
a series of dates but
for probably 10 years I never really had
were coming to the like system how come
verse in dating I'm not in any rush okay
no no I'm loving this so take your time
so you know you Tim I remember coming to
these sort of sway no BLC events or in
Hoffman my firm used to come in these
things and they were awesome and so I
and you know I ended up having some
decent dating life because I would do
these things mostly just because I was
not around very often I was just pick a
day and then everybody would be there
and five years sort of ten years I was
sort of single guy in Manhattan and a
friend like to describe it as you know
you have junk eating whether you just
moved from car it was sort of like junk
dating like there's a high on the first
date and then that high is still sort of
there but on the second date and then it
fades on the third day and so then you
go the next one because there's a high
and so Manhattan life is full of this
sort of junk dating like you have the
junk eating thing you go from one to
another and then you never it's really a
bad bad place for dating I think because
you never there's so many carbs around
yeah everyone's looking for the next
shiny penny and you don't actually take
the time to really relish and savor and
get past a couple little speed bumps to
find the what's really valuable
underneath anyway I'd been dating five
or five years six years seven years and
at that point my father had gotten ill
and and then passed away from cancer
from a rare type of leukemia and that I
think gave me a mind shift like what am
I doing here and I had been doing this
sort of mindless kind of like the garry
kasparov con takes bishop well that
didn't work out with that dating thing
so let me not date you know some woman
who looks like this was in the
profession wired as this characteristic
so okay so that solves you know that's
one pawn takes Bishop don't do this move
don't do that move but I'd never step
back and said like what am i dis
systematically like what's wrong you're
like why they you know not dated
one for more than two months or three
months and like in a bunch of years and
I took a weekend and I just said all
right let me be really try to be really
honest with myself like you know I do
want something more serious I want a
life partner let me just think through
you know the last ten or twenty you know
dates that I've got or women that I've
gone on some kind of date with like why
did it not develop is there any pattern
here what was I thinking when I again
what was your decision-making process
that you wanna and then when I was
pretty honest about it and stepped back
and looked at it from view above I you
know there was a pattern that came out
and I was like this is stupid I'm doing
this same pattern over and over and I
need to be thinking in a completely
different way and I need to be making my
decisions about who I date and why I
date them in a totally different way I
know where we're getting into like a
therapy session here or or or person a
lot of personal details but are you open
to sharing what the pattern was this is
just between you and me right it's just
what you got it all right you know I am
I you know I think one of the lessons
there is that no matter how self-aware
you think you are you're really
influenced by your surroundings a lot
more at least I was really influenced by
who I was surrounded with more than I
appreciated I thought oh I am my own
person that doesn't matter but at the
time I had a number of friends who were
in the film and fashion world and so I I
didn't have a lot of time to arrange
social life stuff because I was flying
all of it and so I would go to social
events for them and they were really
interested in another film and so a lot
of my dates were like film and fashion
or occasionally I would you know meet
some other variants and they were really
especially interested in kind of some of
the more superficial qualities
and sort of fast dating based on like
superficial stuff and how people look or
how people
and as much as I thought I was a good
guy I sort of fell into that trap and of
dating based on much more superficial
and I because I was able to make
conversation reasonably well and have a
good time I could have a fun first or
second worth and then kind of fool
myself into thinking oh I really connect
with this person because look at these
really interesting conversations you
mentioned Richard Feynman one of the
great finding quotes is the most
important thing is not to fool yourself
and you need to remember that you're the
easiest person to fool and I was fooling
myself I was saying oh I'm really into
that person because there are great
people person and we have all these
great people insights you know meanwhile
the person wants to go to clubs and you
know midnight or 1 a.m. and like that's
the last thing I have any interest in
doing and so when I said I'm really
being influenced I need to just step out
of this I need to actually break up with
some of my guy friends which is a weird
thing to think but you know you get kind
of reliant and then you just sort of
follow I need to break up because this
is influencing me and I need to make
different decisions about who I want to
go out on dates with because that stuff
is not really me it's not deeply who I
it's not who I am in my core and I'm
making the first few conversations fun
but then I'm getting bored and I had an
old friend who told me there was sort of
two criteria for finding the right life
partner it was a New York guy and he was
a very easy older guy and you know it
was a mentor and he very successful so
very good-looking very sort of classic
Midwest gentleman and been very
successful in dating and had learned a
lot because he was on his third wife
okay this is a footnote but very happily
married and I think you learn more by
some failure obviously than success so
you learned a lot he said just two
criteria one mental health because and
especially Manhattan that's a really
that's a pretty high bar and
to find somebody like having dinner with
because you can be having a lot of
dinners together and if that's not
appealing to you it's going to be a
tough marriage and the physical stuff
takes care of itself because you know
you want you won't be there but the that
was just a gray circle stuff meaning
it's either there or it isn't yeah and
you know that within the first few and
you're just not going to go that and
it's so overrated it's so overemphasized
anyway that's not something you need to
think about what's under emphasized is
stuff you're more likely to miss and
it's just a really nice straightforward
litmus test how much do you like having
dinner together and what I realized it's
like when I went back and looked i
wouldn't rank high you know how much i
like to have dinner with you know the
people i've been dating and so that's
what i started looking for people who
were more just an intellectual mind fit
for me and less worried about any of the
other stuff less worried what any friend
would think or anybody would think or
anyone around me I've had you're smiling
I'm smiling because I I want to ask just
a few follow-up questions and I know
that I'm jumping in a lot but this is
what I do anyway like we're if we were
having drinks I'd be doing it okay I'll
be doing exactly the same thing and you
mentioned peer group and there's sort of
two at least two components of I'd
imagine making a shift one is breaking
up with some of your friends and then
the other is gathering the people you
hope to be positively influenced by
right and I think for a lot of people
listening the latter part is the easier
part I like adding more people right is
the easier part did you break up with
your friends by doing the slow drift
where it's like by the time you were
gone they don't didn't really notice
because it was very gradual or did you
do it more directly how did you break up
with people well firstly we're guys so
we don't talk about yeah right it's not
really
I think women have a much more
communicative thing and guys are just
like oh whatever
like we're gonna answer a couple texts
so you know whatever it's also Manhattan
yeah so you know the social life is like
let's text you know 10 friends at 5 p.m.
and see what's going on at 7 p.m.
and you know whichever - you find me and
so after a while you don't answer some
of those texts it's like so breaking up
with some guy friends turns out you know
not to be a heavy that has to be a heavy
lift but of course it depends on the gut
you know and but yeah this breaking and
then finding people who you think are
more resonant you really kind of excite
you and you really enjoy and are more
the way you want to be aspirationally
how you want to live your life and you
know through that process I mean not
long after I did that system mindset
it's supposed to outcome mindset on
dating you know I went out on a couple
day and there was just totally different
level I enjoyed them at a much different
level because I was really you know how
much my genuinely enjoying dinner as
opposed how much I might you know
telling stories trying to be funny and
it was funny and she laughed and that's
great let's go to bed or whatever this
thing's not on right nope the bikes are
okay good that's great
so that never happened by the way honey
you're the first really I'm gonna be in
trouble I think we have magic and
post-production if needed anyway so I
know it just started and very shortly
thereafter I I was sort of set up on a
introduction I call it a date my wife
calls it a business meeting so there's a
slightly different perspective here I I
don't know if you know this story do you
know I said you were at the wedding I
was at the wedding but I don't know okay
so I was at a cocktail event at there
was a theatre group actually Katherine
was at the wedding - who was responsible
for all this
there was a theatre production group in
New York and they had their annual gala
and I you know went to raise the flag in
support and
it's full of kind of artists and you
know fill theater people that I didn't
you know know the first thing about
theater or a lista so I would just like
went to line two went on line two for a
drink just to like hide out and have an
excuse not to talk to people and there
was a guy standing next to me who said
oh hey you know you know my name is so
so what is your and what do you do and I
said oh I I do medical research because
in bought in New York nobody knows what
at the time nobody knew what biotech was
and he said oh that's interesting my
ex-girlfriend does cancer research in
Boston and I'm all of a sudden like my
ears perk up my antenna goes up like
ding ding ding ding ding really because
this was this was a pretty good-looking
dude he was kind of this tall and you
know nice-looking guy and he was clearly
well-adjusted and kind of a likable guy
and I thought a cancer research and
busts and that's what I do that's what I
would be if this guy's pretty
good-looking his ex-girlfriend is
probably pretty hot see she's probably
pretty well-adjusted because if you know
most science and science are there so
few that they just the the guys are like
sharks but if she can interest a guy who
doesn't know any science who's pure arts
she must be kind of a well-rounded
personality so ABC I'm like ding ding
ding ding ding and because I was already
on the lookout because of this system
and said I couldn't on whom I'm dating
and so within about the first 30
milliseconds I'm like how can I stalk
this guy electronically tomorrow figure
out who his ex-girlfriend is and then
somehow accidentally arrange to pump
into her and this was all like within
the first you know right he's just
talking your night just like mentally
you know like having the next day
planning like tomorrow I'm gonna figure
out like does he know the woman who's
hosting and then can I find out like
what his last name is and can anyway I'm
doing all these calculations in my and
then so he says you know that's so when
he asks you know like how do you know
what's your connection I explained I
remote
buy a ticket I said you know I run a
biotech company in Boston and cancer
research who's her advisor oh I know
that guy doesn't it up and he says oh do
you mind if I introduce you because she
might be interested in a job in industry
and I'm thinking like ding ding ding
ding me yeah I'm like sure well I'll see
if I can make the time for that meeting
and then I go home and the next morning
I'm thinking all right where did the
odds it's Saturday night in New York
some guy in line for a drink tells you
something about his ex girl that he's
actually gonna follow through this is
less than 10% chance right so I'm
already thinking like how do I figure
out who this guy was sorta and then I
get this email and it you know he's like
Oh Safi and Margit I want to introduce
you you know Martha is interested in
so-and-so and Safi does you know
such-and-such and later I found out he
googled me and there's you know there
was this kind of profile written about
me online and there was a little video
and sweet forwarded all that stuff to
her I didn't know that at the time but
anyways so I get this email and then so
10 milliseconds later I google her and
now comes this like model pose like this
like I'm like what the freaking hell
that's a cancer biology PhD who's a
postdoc at Harvard oh my god I am so
taking this meeting and so then I
arranged to meet her and then we meet up
one week later and it was supposed to be
like just a coffee after it's the least
romantic I was down at the dana-farber
Cancer Center for some meetings and she
was working right in your boss we met at
the like Longwood Medical gallery oh the
least right you know your doctors and
scrubs everywhere and it's just like
fast food court and like there's some
cheesy little hotel there with its
cheesy little restaurant I forgot the
name and you know sit down 5 o'clock bus
to be a 30 minute coffee and it turns
into five hours I like neither I don't
even notice the time and for the first
time I feel like I'm not trying yeah I'm
not like trying to be entertaining or
tell a story or blah blah blah just like
since the actual me and she's like a
female version of me no not really but
like female version - 14 years and you
know I'm very attractive
all sorts of other from the Czech
Republic bathroom Israel and New Jersey
but other than that very you know she
just she really cared about science and
the search for truth and family I really
didn't care for anything else like all
this stuff of the glitz or you know
financial or material stuff and you know
that's this is really sadly pretty
common in Manhattan she just had no
interest she just liked the science she
was doing and figuring out good science
and she cared deeply about family and
that was it and she knew what she cared
about and she clearly just had fantastic
values and I was like this woman is
awesome because that's how'd it work out
and I would say eight months later you
got the wedding invitation amazing yeah
beautiful wedding thank you all so thank
you and so this this is I like the the
weaving that we're doing from sort of
personal the business because it's same
same same but different I like that a
lot of the thought processes behind them
and and one thing I was helping to do
today also which you're doing great job
of doing yourself but it is humanizing
you in the sense that if I read a very
simple bio of you but if we got into a
lot of the details you can be very
intellectually intimidating I think you
could be you're very smart guy and
there's there's no doubt some hard
wiring that helps with that but you also
use systems and you enable yourself with
tools and so you mentioned no BLC right
and you said very quickly and passing
well I can't remember anything unless I
use acronyms so let's talk about
acronyms just for a second because this
this type of shorthand can be really
helpful what other acronyms
have you used and there their whole
bunch that that pop up I mean literally
many many many acronyms that you use so
you know I'm looking at one here but you
can start with any one you like one FBR
right FBR what the hell does that mean
but what are what are some other whether
it's sort of heuristics or acronyms that
you use to help perform better make
better decisions anything all right
right FBR okay so that's one of the
writing rules of thumb that I learned
that was one of the most important ready
I broke after a year or two or three I
kind of broke out writing for myself
into style story and process and I had
kind of a old story in process so I had
kind of five rules on style that I
worked on an iterator I kind of five
rules on story that I worked on an array
of five rules on just writing process
which is sort of writing routine but
probably one of the most important ones
on the routine process was write FBR so
that stands for write fast bad and wrong
and the reason that that's so important
is that especially if you have any kind
of perfectionistic tendencies and I know
a lot of people write about this but FBR
is what resonated for me and how I
remember it
it just means when you're starting to
write let's say you've found the idea
and the narrative thread and the thing
that you're the wheels are turning and
you think you can see you know the fog
it's like driving you know you're in a
you can only see a few feet ahead with
because you're in a fog and there's sort
of the mists clear and like oh I see I
see where I'm going with this thing
let's just go the inclination is when
you write a sentence or a paragraph for
the first couple paragraphs is to stop
and backtrack either for style or for
facts like I'm doing nonfiction right so
I'm not doing fiction so you know in
such and such date this guy did this
thing and then he did that thing like
was it really that date and
go check the internet so you want to
write F so that is a disaster you'll
never get anything done if you do that
so the trick is to go exactly 180
especially if you have an rife FBR right
if write fast bad and wrong put the
wrong date you don't get the start the
sentence doesn't sound good
great write fast write bad and write
wrong the terrible style terrible
grammar terrible word choice wrong facts
and that liberates you that liberates
you to follow the narrative thread just
keep going and going with it and not
stop and backtrack because every time
you stop but memory is like a car going
on the highway it's easy to stop but
then you have to spend all this fuel to
get back up to speed and you might not
get there so once you're finally going
what you often discover you read a lot
too is like once you start reading and
start pulling on that narrative thread
like it's just really surprising where
it goes but only if you go fast yeah not
if you go slow not if you say oh is it
1941 he did this or was it 1939 was he
with this person or was he with that
person am i spelling his name correctly
let's go check on the internet then
you've lost the thread and what it hurts
on many levels not only do you get less
done but you lose the creativity because
it's only when you're at high speed to
like and the wheels are turning you're
like oh wait wait oh the oh I could go
here no oh I could go there and oh I
could go here like when you're driving
fast you can make a left turn it has a
big impact yeah I think you've got a
slow no it's just thinking you know
creativity and there are many different
types of creativity but it's it's in
some ways a lot like riding a bike right
it's easier at slightly higher speeds
exactly right you try to ride a bicycle
really really slowly and you're twisting
and turning and trying to keep your
balance and it's herky-jerky and the
stopping and starting that task
switching is really expensive funny
you're saying that because in the
physics of that is the angular momentum
of the wheels and once you have high
angular momentum you're much more stable
than at low angular momentum yeah so I
was gonna I was gonna die Gress into
motorcycles
second but would of course mean a part
of the fun of having our conversations
is that the it's just a beautiful medley
of digressions but trying to maintain
some semblance of professional
podcasting protocol we could go out at
motorcycle digression - I got motorcycle
start but that's another welcome back to
motorcycles we're gonna segue to other
subject areas but what other we're not
going to go through all the rules for
style story and process but I'm curious
particularly about processor but it
could be any are there any other rules
that you have found to be particularly
valuable for writing the jump to mind
it's the it's the hats it's for me I
realized and again a lot of this stuff
took a long time there are two hats you
wear on reading and there - hat there
are three hats you wear on writing and
you just want to be very clear about
what hat you're wearing when so you
don't confuse them and then you're much
more efficient so in you asked about
acronyms I have some really silly I
don't think you've ever said these out
loud it's more like inner inner voice
acronyms but since you're an old friend
that's what I want and this like this
thing is definitely not on so in reading
they're two modes to hats you wear or at
least for me and the first one I call
Rickles and the second one I call Reese
okay
you're laughing I could tell it's like
silly and stupid but that's how I think
about it Rickles is reading for
information content lessons Ric Ric
whatever it is whatever it is Rickles
reading for information content lessons
and stories Rickles and so that's for
the raw me if you're writing nonfiction
there that's for like the raw meat of
the the facts or the ideas of the story
and you're really reading for
information for content and for lessons
and when you say reading or you meaning
are you referring to
to research that you're doing got it so
that's be the researcher let's say
writing about World War two then your
that's in Rickles you're reading very
fast if you you know as fast as you can
and as deeply as you can and chasing
different threads and different
footnotes on different archival and that
is the Rickles hat you're reading for
the information for the content or for
the lessons you want to use or for the
stories you want to tell Rickles totally
different hat is Reis reading for ear
art and skill are EAS so when I was
reading Nabokov Nabokov for example I
was reading for kind of the musical
rhythm and the pacing and the the tricks
that he uses on transitions and or
others he wasn't the only one I would
did that Donald hall whose book essays
after he was a again I'm kind of
ignorant when it comes to literature a
lot of people knew this I did he was a
poet Laura is a poet was I go the first
time I'm hearing is there I remember
talking to like some English friends and
I laughed at me that I didn't know who
he was but anyway some friend had sent
me this essays and I picked that up and
as a poet he also has incredible word
choice and rhythm and pacing and it's
very different than the Boca Nabokov is
fun but it completely eccentric and a
completely unique style that only
applies if you're a Russian émigré who
plays with the dictionary for fun so
it's not relevant for copying it's just
interesting to develop ear and but in a
book of his cold
he's clearly as he's writing for
entertaining himself with language he
doesn't have any he was the first to say
I don't have any messages I don't have
any morals and you can sort of tell he
doesn't really care about his characters
he's just plain he's playing with
language Hall is warm
he wrote wrote a just passed away sadly
he wrote so movingly and sparingly about
incredibly deep emotional personal
things you know his love affair with his
how he fell in love with his you know
wife and
how he thought he would out she would
outlive him and how they made all these
plans and then she came down at an early
age with leukemia and he just couldn't
believe that he was out burying her and
she was just but he writes it in not a
maudlin way at all and he writes it so
beautifully and so powerfully and so
tightly so I read Hall for how do you
write about emotion which I had zero
experience especially as a scientist
emotionally it's not like a top skill
fine and communicating emotion was not
something I had any skill in doing so I
read him not only for the beautiful but
very different writing style but also
for how do you write about emotion honey
read about people how do you write about
characters you know kind of a poetic way
not over telling but using as few words
as possible anyway that's Reis so I want
to pause for one second because I've
been able to see the output of that in
loon shots for instance in the very
beginning and some of the stories you
told patients it's a great example
he's like the output of training that
ability that you did not consider
yourself as that faculty that you didn't
consider yourself as having had
developed right absolutely and and I
want to I'm not gonna well I'm gonna
interrupt but not for very long because
I do want to get to the the writing side
but I want to underscore for folks who
are like why are we talking about
writing with a physicist biotech
entrepreneur and the the reason we're
talking about it is because it's it's
it's same same but different what what
I'm really fascinated by is how you
structure your thinking and question and
stress test your thinking so just for
people who are like why are we talking
about writing that's why so please
continue okay so the theme is about
anchor name or the the other writing
lesson bathies melt these multiple hats
so in in reading it was Rickles I'm now
I'm gonna put on my hat has nothing to
do with style so just shut up shut off
that part of the brain you reading
really fast for a story or a content and
then Reese I'm reading for ear art and
skill
so it's just pure writing skill and so
the way I trained for it is to think
strategically about where am i weak so I
can explain a technical idea pretty well
that's what I've been doing my whole
life whether in academic science we
running a biotech company trying to
explain technical stuff about how a drug
works or the biology or chemistry to
people who are not as technical so
explaining an idea I can do and even in
plain English but books that just
explain ideas are boring I don't even
like reading them people don't really
connect to ideas people connect to
people if you can tell a story tell a
story about people through which an idea
is revealed that's the best of our world
so just talking about ideas is a so-so
just talking about people then you're
sort of a fairy tale but if you can
combine the two tell stories of people
through which an underlying ideas
revealed and through itchin which is
connected by an underlying idea which is
what I tried to do this book that's for
me the grander challenge that was really
kind of a big challenge how do you not
do a and not to be but do the
combination of a and B and so I was not
good at telling stories of people you
don't really do that in academic science
you read a paper you're not gonna write
a paper saying well let me tell you
about the day I first had this idea and
then I was wrong about this and then
joke that's not how you write an
academic paper and when you run a
biotech company you know when you're out
up you know you do your earnings call if
you're public or you're at a you know
investment meeting and you do your 25
minute Roadshow you know you know let me
tell you a story about how you know the
failures and the characters and the drug
know they're like what's your you know
what's your what was your in despair
just the facts ma'am just the facts so
we've talked about the two hats of
reading what are the three hats of
writing the three hats of writing
there's hunting or the way I think about
it is there's hunting there's drafting
and there's editing so in hunting you're
looking for the narrative thread that's
going to hold your story together or if
you do nonfiction you're you're the
the series of stories in the series of
anecdotes and the lesson you're going to
draw so that's the hunting the drafting
is where you're writing FBR fast batting
around just as fast as you can and then
the editing is where it all comes
together you try to make it you know you
get rid of all the glitches and make it
shine and you know as we're talking I
was thinking about this movie who took
me to see this premiere he took me to
see yesterday by Robert Rodriguez where
he made this amazing movie for seven
thousand dollars and before that he was
talking about a master class he was
doing his master class in film and which
was just really a master class in
creativity and he was talking about how
in film he thinks of making a film as
also in three stages like cooking where
you write your recipe then you go
grocery shopping and then you do the
editing at the end it's like you're
cooking I think it's very similar in
writing the hunting the finding that the
narrative thread is like your recipe the
drafting fast bad and wrong the FBR
writing fast as you can is like going to
a supermarket and just filling your cart
as fast as you can with all this stuff
and then it all comes together in the
editing so it's it's a very interesting
hearing that from Robert Rodriguez
because it just reminded me of the kind
of the three hats that I wear when I'm
running well Maps almost perfectly you
it and he used index cards like a pack
of index cards you can get for probably
a dollar two dollars and it's like this
could change your life like one pack of
index cards and lay it on the floor and
then rearrange the order and so on so
like you said that's the hunting for the
structure right or the Ark and then same
as you
fast bad and wrong in quick drafting and
then assembling it and in some respects
with film is slightly different but
improvising on the fly when things go
wrong or other opportunities to present
themselves in on the actual say set or
day of shooting when you are doing the
hunting did you have for instance a a
within chapter structure that you tried
to stick to where there were their
common ingredients
with a chapter where you would try to
say start with a story then add facts
then close with a story or what did you
look at it as more of an arc and a build
over the course of the book or perhaps
both how did you how did you how did you
approach the the hunting portion I'd
love to say at a system or method but I
it absolutely not I'd literally started
with a blank page and almost panic I
actually had to learn I had it one of my
rules is patience / panic because you
start with a blank page and I just had
absolutely no idea what was going to
happen where was gonna go what story I
would you know end up with all these
kind of crazy stories in fact I see
probably the nicest thing somebody said
to me about the book it was this guy
named Bob Sutton who wrote this book and
no [ __ ] rule I was a good guy very
funny guy we were having beers at the
Dutch goose in Menlo Park which I used
to go to 20 years ago and he's been like
a lifelong customer since he was like 12
and we're in like the second or third
beer and there's there's another author
friend of ours there and at some point
he turns to me and he goes your book and
I go yeah I said man that was some wacky
[ __ ] cuz you know I did Pan Am and and
Einstein and Kepler and Steve Jobs and
u-boats and I feel like in some ways
that would look to the nicest thing
anybody said to me oh yeah I think I
think wacky [ __ ] is is a strong
endorsement yeah and I you know when you
asked like what did I do to get these
like wacky stories at each chapter there
all of them are so different like you
know comparing want rip at Pan Am with
Popkin in American or or Steve Jobs in
jef raskin versus isaac newton and
robert hooke you know comparing across
two centuries I have absolutely no clue
where they I would just lock myself in
my little cave shut the blinds and I
would just I would disappear into some
zone and then I would reimburse at 5:30
to pick up my daughter from daycare and
I'd look at what where the hell did that
come from I have no idea so to answer
your question I have no
I would just look at a blank page and
then I'd look up at 5:30 and this list
weird weird what did you go wacky [ __ ]
mr. Solow and that's the grocery shop
but you know we were talking about the
Robert Rodriguez film and it's once you
start that's the advantage of writing
FBR writing fast but wrong you said once
you start going in high speed just like
all this stuff just the speed is really
important yeah and I've always thought
since I sort of had three rules for
everything creativity for me is about
speed attention and courage you want to
go as fast as you can't like for me
getting the stories is about speed
reading so I read through you know I had
so many sources and some I think I'd
like about 5,000 files I mean I scanned
almost all the books so I have
everything electronic and I could search
from the database electronically it was
just reading as fast as I could because
eventually something that's number two
first is speed second is attention
because you want to be reading as fast
as you can and all of a sudden there's a
tiny little thing like whoa wait what
and that's where you got the visual I
have because I've sort of a visual for
everything is a year there's this dense
forest of stuff which is all the facts
and data and stories and there's this
beautiful clearing on the inside which
is like a central core idea and you're
looking for the path in and so you're
running around the circle of as fast as
you can and you're looking for like a
path in or something to guide maybe
you're looking for like a little red
sparrow
that's like hiding that's gonna peek out
behind a little leaf or a tree and
you're running or you're looking looking
and running in scope as best you can and
then all of a sudden you see that so you
need speed you need attention to keep
your eye out for that tiny little you
don't read sparrow to say I'm over here
this is the path and then you need
courage because it may look like a
really wacky sparrow you have some balls
to really follow that idea because your
first thought is there's just no way
there's no way I could compare a Steve
Jobs and Isaac Newton that's absurd well
let me pull on that a little bit more oh
it turns out Steve Jobs didn't really
develop the Macintosh he had
this assistant named naughty didn't have
an assistant there was a guy working at
Apple who had been working on this
project that he called the Macintosh
project for you know a year or two
before jobs and he tried to interest
jobs and in jobs dismissed it and
eventually just because of by default
after jobs had kind of messed up the
Alisa and Apple three I was the only
project they could you know fine and
history got rewritten that like oh he
invented it that's not really what
happened but that's kind of what
happened with Isaac Newton oh he just
came up with the idea of gravity well
actually there was a guy who was much
less charismatic much less good
communicator
named Robert Hooke who came up with a
couple of the central ideas of gravity
and he sort of fed them to Isaac Newton
and then Isaac Newton ran with it
just like Jef Raskin kind of fed the
ideas of a graphical user interface and
a small computer called the Macintosh it
already had the name to Steve Jobs now
Steve Jobs was a much more charismatic
much better communicator in some ways
much more ambitious and shoved him aside
just like Isaac Newton was it had a lot
of skills that the other guy didn't have
I mean Steve Jobs was a great
synthesizer he could bring in marketing
and motivate people the way that Jef
Raskin couldn't you realize we're going
on a really long tangent here okay but
Isaac Newton also you know had some
better skills but he was really fed this
the early ideas by a guy named Robert
Hooke so for creativity what I found was
like speed attention and courage because
you have to say the idea of comparing
Steve Jobs and Jef Raskin with Isaac
Newton and Robert Hooke sounds nuts who
would ever do that but you have to have
some balls to go after it strikes me
also that it's a one could look at it
not just as a potential sequence but
also as a hierarchy in the sense that if
you don't have speed you're not going to
be able to develop the 360-degree view
to have the attention yield any fruit so
you need to have that as a
the precursor to the attention then the
attention is a precursor to the to the
courage which is sort of the execution
on what you find that little red speck
yeah that's exactly right there it's an
order
speed detention courage and that's kind
of what I found for me was the secret of
creating wacky [ __ ] and if we if we if
we come out again to look at the world
of business and not fooling yourself or
not confusing process and outcome and
trying to really have to read something
correctly and I should know it also that
these different hats and these different
heuristics is for being clear on your
purpose before say reading a book or
selecting a book in the first place
is is really really really important and
I give it give an example that
illustrates this in in a very different
context so Tony Robbins doesn't exercise
at some of his events where I'll ask
people to scan the room and I'll say
before you scan the room I want you to
note anything red of reddish hue
remotely close and they do that for 60
seconds and he says all right run
through the list of all the things that
you saw that were red and then he asks
people now note without looking around
the room what you saw that was blue
right and people can't do it right and
it's it's to have that search function
sort of set in place before reading a
book before editing right is really
really really really critical let's talk
about and I think the term that you use
is false failures or false fail all
right let's talk about that for a second
because it also might tie in to someone
we mentioned it at the very beginning of
the conversation who is it was Peter
teal but he talked about what what a
what what a false fail or false failure
is
so fall fell is the idea let's say
you're nurturing some crazy idea that
everybody thinks is nuts which I I
called for lack of a better word I call
that a loon shot rather than a moon shot
I'm going to try everybody knows whether
there's a big goal and a exciting
destination but you know the the big
ideas that really make a divot transform
whether it's an industry or science or
even world history almost never arrive
dazzling everybody with their brilliance
there tend to be the ones that are
floating around for years or sometimes
decades and that people championing them
are written off as nuts mm-hmm in the
revisionist history looking back it's
like oh it's obvious that it was right
sort of a natural tendency to assume
that and that guy was obviously a genius
but most people don't talk about the
fact that everyone said he was an idiot
for 20 years including some of the most
famous people and famous discoveries we
know of but what you see with loon shots
with these crazy ideas is very often
people give up on them because of what
you might call a false fail because and
if by a false fail I mean it was a flaw
in the experiment rather than the idea
the outcome is the same
you know the experiment gave a negative
result and everybody walks away in
science that's the case experiment gave
a negative result everybody walks away
but the problem is not with the idea
it's with the experiment so the example
you mentioned Peter teal so the example
I use is I think I I might have first
heard about this from Ken Howry it's
probably another mutual friend yeah so I
think ken was telling me this one time
over drinks this was like many years ago
yeah Ken who was that who was at PayPal
with with Peter part of the PayPal mafia
that's right each other from Stanford
days or something yeah and then later
Founders Fund and so Ken head started
working with Peter on his private
investments this was just a few months
or a year before it turned into Founders
Fund and so he was kind of helping him
out and he mentioned that this guy's
Zuckerberg had come by Mark Zuckerberg
with this idea for
a social network and everybody had been
social networks have been around for you
know a decade at that point and they'd
all gone nowhere there was a dozen of
them like and you and I can remember all
these crazy names of all these things
you know a small world I'll try whatever
always seems like went and flamed out
and at the time there was another one
that was rising was sort of the popular
one at the time called Friendster which
some people may remember and that was
just starting to flame out and people
were leaving
Friendster for the new thing at the time
which was called MySpace
so when Zuckerberg was going around Ken
was telling me the story
everybody had kind of passed past on
investing because everybody said well
look at look at all the social network
every minute Bishop takes pawn they said
all these guys fail you know and you
know why they feel we know why they fail
because you can see that they're all
these users are hopping from network to
network and that's the outcome right
that's the bishop they come on it lost
the game all these social networks are
going nowhere there's no money in them
so no we're not giving our money to this
Zuckerberg kid or whatever his name is
and can and and Peter said is that
really why they're failing let's take a
look and so they had friends behind the
scenes at Friendster I don't remember if
they were investors or not or whatever
but you know it's a small community and
they said let's ask for the data for the
user retention data like people are
clearly fleeing and we know that they
they were using Friendster and like the
website was kind of glitchy and it was
sort of crashing so they got the data on
the user attention and Friendster and
they found holy crap like people are
staying on this site for hours now this
is a site that's crappy no offense to
whoever is listening who is part of that
team but like this site is crashing all
the time and they happen to know that
they'd been given advice on like listen
you need to build you know you've scaled
from a few users to like a few million
you need to improve your systems because
your site is glitchy and what they
realized is that people were staying on
for
hours even though it was a crappy
glitchy website and that the myspace
just had a better website so they
realized it wasn't that it was a bad
business model like clothing fads and
that everybody that's what people
thought it was like you know you just
switch everybody will switch on mass
every every season they were actually
great but people were staying forever on
these sites these guys just had a bad
website they had a software glitch so it
was a false fail it was a false fail of
Friendster they it was a flaw in the
experiment in the in the in the process
by which people were making their
judgment not a flaw an underlying idea
balloon shot the crazy idea that social
networks had some value so the tli wrote
Zuckerberg a cheque for 500,000 the side
money or non family and friends and
Facebook that's right I think in eight
years later he sold it for a billion
dollars and that's how paying attention
to a false fail can be very lucrative so
let's see here there's another name I
wanted to bring up who I am blanking
here it begins with Sir James Blake
black excuse me James black so who is
Sir James black and What did he say to
you at one point that that sticks in
memory because this this this may relate
in some way oh so he was Annie passed
away you know a few years ago as well so
he was a Nobel prize-winning
pharmacologist chemists biochemists
chemist from Scotland and he in some
ways revolutionized drug discovery he's
one of the first what legendary what
people called now drug hunters he just
had a nose for identifying great new
drugs and so when I met him I think he
was already in his 80s but we got him
interested in what we were doing there
were things that he liked about you know
our little team or a little band of
biologists and chemists and
at a sort of a little you know we went
against the grain of what people said
you should be doing and that kind of
appealed to him so he would fly over
periodically from Scotland and advise
our team and I remember when one night
he'd flown over remember this is like an
80 year old guy and he had flown over
you know some transatlantic flight and
they ended in the morning and it
probably had like a twelve or fourteen
he just went through the whole day of
like research research you know stories
and he'd been talking the whole day and
Stinney ins feet and we're at you know
some the end of like some dinner and I
am like dropping dead of exhaustion and
I'm probably in my mid-30s or whatever
early forties at the time and I'm just
like I just want to go home to bed
because this was a long day and he's
like and so I'm getting up to like going
good no softly stay staying like past me
on this sit down sit down come up with
whisky with me I can't do a Scottish yet
but that's what you know and it's like
come have a whisky like everybody else
leaves and I'm like oh my god I can how
is this 80 year old guy just like full
of it so we get some whiskies and then
he's like I you know I tells us like why
he loves what we're doing and this and
that and then you know he starts well
let me tell you when I was and he like
starts with like the Korean War oh my
god like that's gonna be a long night
ever gonna need a shot of adrenaline or
something just to stay alive but I mean
they're fascinating stories of like this
guy really developed to phenomenal drug
categories that saved millions of lives
so I'm and so we start talking he tells
me this stuff and at some point I tell
him about how there's this project in
the lab that I'm feeling kind of
depressed about because I was really
excited about and it's not you know it
hit this negative result and he Pat's me
on the knee again and goes oh my boy
it's not a good drug unless it's been
killed three times and I I took away
from that as I really it kind of gave me
pause and made me rethink and then as I
ended I started going through more
histories and stories the revisionist
histories that you read about my great
discovery so I had this idea
day and then I showed it to people on
Tuesday and we're all excited on
Wednesday and it worked on Thursday and
the drug was approved on Friday that is
not what happens these people with these
great ideas they get killed like really
the project gets terminated everybody
hates it it's pulled it but people say
oh it's tough to kill a project let me
be a big man and kill a project it's
really easy to kill a project you just
say no if you're in charge you just say
no funding you're done and it never
comes back
no one's gonna work on a dead project so
no one can prove you wrong
you seem like a big man it's really easy
it's actually hard to keep a project
going why because any good crazy idea
stumbles and fails like like Jim said it
gets killed three times it has these
terrible favors it seems like a really
bad idea it doesn't work it looks like
it's not gonna work out and then if you
have a really great champion or you get
really lucky you survive that failure in
all of his projects but he won the Nobel
Prize for the two drug categories a beta
blockers and a histamine antagonists
failed like that multiple time and so
that's what he meant and then when you
look back in history like the statin
drugs I tell a little bit of that story
probably the you know saved millions of
lives for been a millions of heart
attacks
they were killed multiple times and they
almost died and disappeared and never
happen and that's I've come to think of
that as the three deaths of the loon
shot the truly important breakthroughs
are killed several times and it it does
go against the grain of this stuff that
you hear in Silicon Valley all the time
I've like vast fail you know fail fast
and pivot fail fast and pivot well okay
but like if you fail fast in pivot
that's probably what everybody else did
when they hit the exact same stumble and
sometimes it's the opposite like
everybody will fail fast and pivot when
they hit that same stumble but if it's
there's something really important
underlying there I mean often that is
the the reason why there's something
really important is because everybody
has turned away from the first stumble
and you need to make it past that first
stumble past the second stumble past the
third stumble and then you have the goal
and that's why it's gold because
everybody gives up on the first or set
because everybody's following fail-fast
and pivot so everybody's given up if
you've persisted through those failures
that's where the really really big
breakthroughs are so let's let's do a
little retrospective on looking at some
historical examples and it may be by way
of example describing what loon shots
are right and I believe there are two
types and we could talk about one and
Bob it's just not a country music duo
give us give us give us some examples of
loon shots and that may be the different
species of of loon shots the two types
so there is the one type I think of as a
technology that everybody says won't
work so you go way back the telephone
people said this is a pointless you know
toy or the transistor there's no way you
could make a switch out of some
solid-state device or personal computer
that's not going to be important or
digital cameras or even jet engines
that's the one and Bob store
jet engines you know there's no way you
could ever make a commercial plane with
a jet engine so those are products or
technologies that everybody says won't
work let's call this p-type the other
thing is this is much less those are
kind of glamorous because ever you can
put a picture of a product on it and I
own P for product P for product for
p-type you can put that on the cover of
a magazine and people get really excited
it there's this there is we're we're at
South by Southwest so there is this
obsession with product product product
product but what people often miss and
this sometimes much more important and
is a dangerous trap if you miss it is
the other kind is a small change in
strategy that involves no new technology
it's a small change in strategy it's
called the s-type that everyone says is
crazy or won't work so what's an example
of that well let's take a story of a
young kid who wanted to go into retail
and wants to open a shop and you know
where all the customers are which is big
cities and then his wife happens to say
well honey you know I'm happy to support
you in this dream of yours but I just
hate big cities I'm only willing to live
where the town is smaller than ten
thousand people so he says ok and he
decides he likes being married he also
likes quail hunting so he knows there's
this region in the middle of America
where the four states come together in a
corner and therefore different quail
hunting season so he puts his store
there and he moves to a little town
called Bentonville Arkansas and he opens
a store and he makes it a little bit
bigger and he sells stuff a little bit
cheaper and he gives us to our name it's
called Walmart
okay now that ends up absolutely
dominating the retail industry and
wiping out everybody else now was he
thinking about let me go disrupt the
retail industry no he had a wife that
didn't want to live in a big town and he
liked quail hunting and he made stuff a
little cheaper so he had small changes
in strategy where he put his store how
big he made his store and you know made
price us a little bit lower
were there any new technologies no he
just sold stuff a little bit did he
invent retail no did he invent selling
stuff a little cheaper no these were
small shifts in strategy that ended up
being incredibly important so those
things are much harder and they're much
less glamorous because they're harder to
write about and harder to prove than the
P type things which are easier to prove
so those are the two types mm-hmm
and just so people aren't left hanging
with with Juan and Bob Juan Trippe PanAm
and Bob Crandall American Airlines but
the the the the example that really I
had actually not had any familiarity
with which which which I think I'd love
you to describe briefly is Robert
Goddard
and the rocket flight in space and
because people credit right other people
namely I guess it would have been JFK
but in could you describe a little bit
of the the backdrop for that slur sure
sorry in fact that gets right to the
moon shot one shot so in 1961 Kennedy
announced in a speech to Congress
his ambition of putting a man on the
moon and of course I was widely
applauded and that's actually where the
term moonshot comes from but as we
mentioned those breakthroughs that get
us there are rarely recognized and
widely applauded at the time so in fact
how did we actually get to them and well
we got to the moon on a rocket my rock
Rockets worked through liquid you know a
liquid fueled jet propulsion so the
principles that got us to the moon were
invented by a guy named Robert Goddard
four decades earlier and he had written
it up he had demonstrated he'd been
working on experiments he had proved it
to pretty good certainty but he was
ridiculed and I found this in the New
York Times this what in the archives
this was pretty hilarious in 1920 I
think it was after Goddard had suggested
his idea that we could get to space with
these liquid fuel rockets in 1920 The
Times came out with an editorial and
said oh this guy you know professor
Goddard with his quote chair they
literally put quotes around the word
chair physics like that's a bad thing
you know air quotes his quote chair in
physics at some university like Clarke
you know like making fun that he wasn't
an Ivy League guy and he was a quote
chair he says this guy you know this
professor doesn't understand the basic
laws of physics that we teach our
children every day seems to lack the
knowledge ladled out daily in high
schools exactly
namely that newton's laws of action and
reaction make rocket flight in space
impossible end of story
so the funny part of that is it like
fast-forward I think it was July 11th
1969 if I remember there was a day of
the day after the Apollo the successful
launch of the Apollo 11 rocket to the
moon the times issues of retraction and
it says apparently rocket flight does
not violate the laws of physics and
quote The Times regrets the error and
even when you've really really put these
seemingly miraculous successes or iconic
structures for instance Eiffel Tower
under a fine
sort of forensic lens and you realize
that I'm not gonna say all of them but
it's certainly a very high percentage
not only encountered resistance but I
mean exceptionally violent and
heavy-handed sort of ad hominem attacks
I mean that the Eiffel Tower everyone
knows at this point and it's an every
brochure and every sales pitch for Paris
in France was opposed by just about
everyone I mean it was it was all uphill
and I want to talk at some point about
how you know smaller teams or
entrepreneurs who are maybe solo maybe
the handful of folks can can think about
embracing or structured thinking around
loon shots but I wanted to jump back to
your personal experience for a second
and again feel free to fact-check this
because you can't believe everything you
read on the internet or in in certainly
not in every book but I have here a
quote from Michelle Wie the golfers
coach who instructed her and this is
from a book the net and the butterfly -
she was given a quote by her coach to
repeat to herself whenever she missed a
putt quote I've gotten that out of the
way now I'm one step closer to becoming
the best putter in the history of golf
end quote
and the the segue is that it's you were
then mentioned afterwards and the quote
is I often think of that quote when I
screw up a is that true B are there how
do you use such a quote or other quotes
as a practice or a reminder it's a lot
of a lot of question at once yeah sure
that's a good research so that that's
for my very good friend Olivia Fox who
was also at the wedding you may have met
her there but she sent me an early draft
and I gave her that quote and it's a
mental reminder of you know whenever you
screw up and anyone who's gotten
anywhere it's because you've been
through those three deaths you've been
called a failure and eighty including
and drafting this book when like
everybody had the same experience every
publisher it's like yeah there's like no
books on you try to mix physics and
business never work and I'm thinking
like really like what book that makes
physics I haven't read any book there's
so many Nevers just like books on
physical fitness cookbooks don't travel
internationally I mean there's so many
endeavors and you're like really like
where's the data on that yeah and so you
know Olivia was a good friend asking for
it and I thought about that at the time
and the the inspiration a little bit is
also tennis so I played in the juniors
as a kid and a gret playing tennis and I
at the time it was it was probably you
know shows how old I am Pete Sampras
versus Andre Agassi was and so both were
you know I admired both Agassi developed
this tick or trick which is at the end
of a bad point if I remember correctly
at the end of a bad point he would slap
his thigh and that was like a mental
little hook to forget about the point is
he just associated with flapping his
with forgetting the bad point that he
just [ __ ] up and focusing on the
current and that was a little trick for
his brain just to stop wallowing in the
bed and focus on now and just the bed
just went away and it's the same thing
with Michele shall we yeah
Michele we and it's you screw up you do
something stupid even in business life
you had a bad board he said stupid
things or you had a bed advice from you
know you did something dumb with an
employee that you regret doing you need
to slap your thigh or think of the
Michelle Wie example like I screwed that
up and that's one step along the way of
me getting better and whatever I'm going
to do now slap the thigh and let's focus
on you know set that behind you and then
move forward and so that's the that's
the kind of golf record or the Andrea I
guess see slap your thigh trick okay
related because you you use and not not
to belabor this but you have you use
systems and reminders a lot yeah why do
you have a post-it note and you may you
may no longer have it but post-it note
that says The Adventures of Luke
Starkiller
oh yeah it's still up on my wall I think
the one on earth is that so I did a lot
of one of the stories I tell I tell a
bunch of film stories I have some one of
my really close friends is a in film and
we've been friends for many many years
and so I've he and I have traded stories
and part of the inspiration was like he
was so fascinating to me how many of my
stories from biotech were so similar to
the stories from film and how what a
biotech CEO does is so similar to what a
film producer does and how the markets
are structured the hundreds of biotech
companies and the hundreds of film and
the few film majors are so similar to
the hundreds of small production shops
and the the few sorry the few film
majors at the top the few pharma majors
at the top and the hundreds of
production shops and the hundreds of
biotech companies the film industry
structure the financing of it the
dynamics of it the focus so it was so
similar to developing a film was so
similar to developing a drug I just
found that
connection fascinating so I tell a fair
amount of film stories in the I realized
my answers are kind of long-winded dear
like I tell a lot of stories to get
there my wife hates that by the way I'm
doing that again I'm like going off on a
tangent story of a tangent this is a
tangent of a tangent of a tange that's
why I do long for him it's why there's a
delete button on those videos I'm sure
anyways the tell a fair number of film
stories I tell the kind of James Bond
story which was a loon shot like Ian
Fleming had written these Bond novels
and he really you know he he didn't have
as much money as some of the as a
lifestyle he aspired to which you can
see in these Bond movies and so he was
really trying to sell the film and
everybody had just written this off like
all the studio's they just weren't
buying and there were a bunch of false
fails I made some TV show which was a
disaster so that was a false feeling oh
yeah it's just and the American studios
were like there's just no way Americans
want to see a British dude with an
accent or they're gonna believe that you
know it's like some heroics by saving
the world like the stories are junk and
he's kind of a metrosexual like who
wants to watch that he's kind of prissy
about his stuff like who wants to see
that and actually even the first when he
finally got it gave up after 8 or 9
years trying to do it and got these like
random producers who you know want to
just bankrupt at his business and they
were trying to sell the movie they just
sold it to some studio and they'd cast
this guy who is 32 years old who had
been in a movie like Tarzan and the
little people or whatever it was I
forgot what the name was and like two
movies and he'd been a milk truck driver
and the Americans they made it for a
million bucks
and this the American studious you know
what this is like this is absurd no
one's gonna want to see literally the
quote was no one's gonna watch a limey
truck driver
you know fighting spies of course that
guy was Sean Connery and but they really
were so sure it wouldn't work they
opened it in Drive in studios I think
wasn't like in Kentucky and Texas all
night let's just put in a couple
drive-in studios and then right at
office a lot and then the reacts the
crowd reaction was like wait what and
then of course it became the greatest
film franchises of all times and the
other the second the two top film
franchises of all time with James Bond
and Star Wars setting it up going way
back
tracing like minute by minute what
happened with Star Wars and if you
search you can actually find the early
drafts there are four early drafts of
the script and you can actually get find
them and I've read the drafts they were
freaking horrific like it was tear the
writing was terrible the storytelling
was terrible the characters were nothing
like the characters that you have at the
end the plot was incomprehensible it
sounded absurd which is you know you
could see why people studios rejected it
at first and one of the titles of one of
the drafts actually this was the
shooting version of the script the first
title was the adventures of Luke
Starkiller and it was such a stupid name
that the hero is called mace windy mace
windy mace windy which sounds like you
know a superhero that farts you know and
it just like it was so bad yet it became
one of the greatest movies of all time
and so I keep that to help me write FBR
write fast bad and wrong you just
realized that all first drafts are [ __ ]
yeah everything when it starts off as
[ __ ] and if star wars when the greatest
movies of all time was just such
horrific [ __ ] in the beginning then
you're probably okay it's alright to
have your stuff sound terrible and
that's okay just keep going
you've fix it up in the editing which is
what they did I knew every line to that
film as a kid when I came out and I
would drive audiences nuts because it's
I think the only film maybe that and et
where I insisted my mom take me to the
movies repeatedly and it was it was for
my family it was it was quite
and indulgence to go to the movies to
begin with right but I knew the entire
movie by heart and a split second before
any character would say a line I would
say the line in the theater which
understandably drove people around me
batshit crazy but stuck with me I had a
huge impact so now I know that mace
windy is to thank for it
how can smaller teams and we have so
much to chat about I mean hopefully we
can do a part to around to with this and
because I would love to and it's so fun
to spend time together but maybe just
with with some of the time that we have
left you could talk about how individual
entrepreneurs or small small teams can
think about moonshots like what is the
significance for a single person or a
small group right so you know kind of
the moral of the story is you want to
nurture these long shot so forget about
you know moon shots or big goals or even
the word disruptive innovation it's a
terrible way it should be crossed out of
every dictionary and taken off of every
website because it's it's misleading
because anybody who's been an
entrepreneur knows that the great idea
the ideas that end up becoming
incredibly important that actually you
know retrospect disrupt the market
nobody knows at the time like Sam Walton
had no clue he just like quail hunting
that's why he went to Bentonville AR had
no clue he wasn't thing
let me disrupt the retail industry by
locating stores and the you're in a
rural America and then building them
somewhat no he was just like his wife
said he didn't want to live in an in the
big city and as he pointed out later we
had no idea what the demand would be so
real innovations are about are less
about market projections and some guru
waving a PowerPoint about you're going
to disrupt this market that's crap a
real innovation that ends up doing
something is like a leaf in a tornado
you just never know
where it's gonna end up anybody tells
you it's gonna end up there it's gonna
be just has not been a real entrepreneur
most of the great like the transistor
they were working on building better
switches for telecom and when they came
up with Bell Labs and when they invented
the solid-state device it turned I was
it wasn't good enough to use in telecom
so they really had no idea what to do
with it it was five years before the
first application which ended up being
in hearing aids so were the scientists
working on the transistor going to their
bosses and let's disrupt the hearing aid
market I have an idea for you know they
were just trying to build better
switches and so the reason you want to
nurture loon shots is to challenge
beliefs it's not you want to use
disruptive innovation if you're a
history professor and you're writing
about what happened in hindsight
otherwise don't use it
yeah Walton disrupted the retail
industry transistor disrupted everything
but that's in hindsight when you're
really there at the time you nurture
loon trust to challenge beliefs to
challenge accepted wisdoms some things
that you think are absolutely true maybe
you're right
but suppose you're wrong do you want to
read about it in a press release from
your competitor or would you rather be
nurturing it in your own lab or trying
it on yourself and seeing how it plays
out so you that's why you're nurturing
shut so what can small teams or groups
do well to succeed with anything just
the idea is a small fraction of if you
think about a football field the idea is
getting you from your own goal maybe to
your own 5-yard line or you aren't in
line just there's a lot of ideas in the
world you want to be able to to take an
idea into a real product you need people
who understand the markets who
understand how to segment tomorrow
understand audiences who understand how
to build or understand their manufacture
and they're seeing on a release I don't
understand
timelines and get anything done on time
on budget on spec and that's the other
ninety yards so you need both
and you can think of one is sort of the
artist and one a sort of the soldier you
have artists that work on their crazy
ideas and you have the soldiers that get
the ball down the other ninety yards and
so you need both and so that's some kind
of one of the things that I get into is
why companies often fail is that they
don't wear those two they don't
understand the separation that you need
for both the Union they're motivated by
two completely different things and you
need to tailor the way you interact with
systems you design the incentives the
metrics totally different almost exactly
opposite for artists and soldiers for
artists you want a high failure rate if
you're not trying stuff and failing
stuff for soldiers you want a low
failure rate like let's let's go to you
know military for aviation the guys who
are coming up with crazy ideas from new
technology if you wanted to try lots of
stuff and crazy things that nobody said
could work in a minute but the guys who
are assembling planes you don't want
them to launch ten planes in the sky and
say well let's see which aid fall in
crash no so it's the exact opposite
things you want to reward so you need to
separate your artists and your soldiers
and design different tools and manage
the balance between the two so that's if
you're a larger company now you asked
about what if you're a smaller company
or a solo so you want to separate your
artists and soldiers you can if you're a
larger company you can separate that by
role and if you're a smaller company you
want to think about separating that by
time you want to be very mindful this is
sort of comes back to that wearing
different hats you want to be very
mindful we're gonna go into a zone where
all we're going to do is the art is
great and we want to maximize failure
and then we're going to step out of that
zone when we've you know listed the
hundred different ideas or in pick the
father and we're going to minimize
failure we want to get this these five
ideas done on time on budget on spec to
Custer's so you need to be very self
aware of what zone are you in and the
confusing thing is when you're running a
small
teamate because you don't have different
people you don't have an artist and a
soul sometimes you do but you want you
don't want to tell your artists all
right I need you to have a 98% success
rate on your ideas like that's I need
you to have two ideas on Monday two
ideas on Tuesday three ideas and when
you know you can't schedule create the
converse is when you're dealing with
your soldiers you don't you want to
create those metrics so in a small team
or small group if you can't separate
that by role you want to separate that
we're all gonna put off our execution
hat or operational excellence hat we're
gonna put on our crazy artists wacky
what ideas could kill our business what
are the things that are floating out
there that we're sure are not right
balloon shots but if they were right
they would kill us what are those things
what are our embedded assumptions our
beliefs about our customers right our
competitors our substitutes the nature
of our market or regulatory or whatever
we know that these are right we know
that our beliefs are true but what's the
opposite suppose they're wrong what
could somebody be doing to kill us let's
just take a week or whatever it is and
think of all the things that we know
we're sure is true what the opposite and
now let's suspend disbelief like a movie
let's suspend disbelief how might
somebody here's that all these reasons
to dismiss it and why could never be
true all the reasons people use to
dismiss saloon shot that's why it's
saloon shot like they made fun of
Goddard facility and Rockets could never
fly in space it's against the laws of
physics all these things that you're
sure true like the New York Times was
sure Newton's laws of physics applied
and rule that you know rocketry all
these things you sure true what if they
weren't or how might a really creative
person getaway around that and how might
that kill us let's just take a week and
walk through all the loony shots that
are out there on our customers or our
markets or our products or whatever it
is whatever you're doing how might they
kill us
and then if we identify those things how
can we flip that around and use that to
knock out our competitors so that's like
take separating the artists and soldiers
but not by role but by time yeah and
then now that we've done that let's take
off that head and now let's focus on
operational excellence on-time on-budget
on spec okay this is not a moment for
like innovative dreaming this is like on
deliver on time on budget on spec and
there you separate by time rather than
by role if you're a small company I this
is and we're gonna wrap up in just a few
minutes but I want to highlight for
people listening how tied together
everything is that we've talked about
throughout this session one of hopefully
at least at least two because I love
hanging out with you and catching up in
the sense that whether it's fast bad and
wrong right right spitting out your two
shitty pages a day or whatever it might
be in other words on an individual level
being clear on the hat that you're
wearing and segmenting by time or within
an extremely large organization
segmenting by role between artists and
soldiers and so on
there are ways to systematize your
generation of ideas vetting of ideas
execution of ideas and you know one of
the reasons I enjoy whether it's having
drinks hanging out at your wedding or
simply batting around ideas with you is
that you're very good at asking
questions that help with clear thinking
which helps with clear action or more
effective action
would you be willing not right now but
some other time to do a round two where
we talk about how to bring a gun to a
knife fight which we kind of alluded to
right right incentives how to apply
incentives to other people to yourself
to teams etc because this is really
really really underappreciated and a
whole bunch of other things that I'd
love to talk to you about would you be
willing to do that let's do it okay
awesome now for those people who are
only going to perhaps get this episode I
highly highly recommend and for those of
you who listen to this show a lot I
don't say that lightly that you grab a
copy of loon shots it is it is
incredibly pragmatic it is very
well-written I was I was really
impressed because with all the time
we've spent together it's like I haven't
the identity that I have sort of painted
on top of this avatar in my head called
Safi is like scientist entrepreneur etc
and I could set a lot of books and I get
sent a lot of books by my friends too
and every time I get one I'm like oh god
I hope this isn't garbage because it's
just gonna be so uncomfortable to try to
like dance around this somehow and it's
a it's a damn good book it really is so
I encourage people moonshots calm take a
look at the book and if you're like I
still need to be sold okay go read go
read up on Safi and you'll be ik okay
they're probably things that I could
learn I'm Safi and from the historical
examples that you weave together right
it's it's really the way that I like to
learn personally and I think it's the
way a lot of humans learn as you pointed
out is through stories that illustrate
points and it's it's tempting I think
and this is another thing that impresses
me about you is too from the influence
of in some cases academics too to speak
in abstractions and conceptual
frameworks without the real-life sort of
human glue that makes it memorable and
then the memorable component is really
important because if if you don't have
the acronyms the stickiness of these
concepts how the hell are you going to
apply them when the times when the time
comes that they're actually important to
implement so check out loon shots at
South people call on Twitter SAF I bah
CA ll we will be continuing the
conversation somehow someway is there
anything else you would like to say
before we wrap up this round one
any questions comments suggestions to
the audience anything at all that you'd
like to say before we wrap up this
versus just it's kind of fun to see you
again and just catch up so yeah looking
forward to part two and before to having
drinks together one of these days and
we're sure catching up some more all
right awesome there's there's so much
more to explore so folks keep an eye out
for round two I'm gonna I'm gonna twist
some arms if necessary bribe with
alcohol if if it's called for and for
links to everything that we've discussed
in this episode all the names mentioned
books etc authors and so on you can go
to the show notes so Tim de Blanc
forward slash podcasts and just search
Safi sa fi or loon shot loon shots and
he will come right up and you'll have
all of it and until next time thank you
for listening
you